hey guys it's justine and today we've
got our hands on the brand new dji osmo
mobile 4. this was just announced by dji
and i've covered their previous gimbals
in the past but this is their latest one
and let's check it out create magnetic
moments if you take a look back here
this is what i'm really excited to check
out so they now have like this magnetic
mount
so they have one that you can mount to
your phone but they also have just the
regular magnetic mount so if you have to
take your phone quickly off of this
thing it's going to be really easy if
you've ever used mobile gimbals before
that's one of the things that's like
once your phone is in there like how do
you
easily take it off back and forth to be
able to use it so i think this is going
to be a good solution
but let's find out
[Applause]
you know what this means this must mean
a new iphone
is on the horizon i can't believe it's
almost iphone season already
crazy
so the previous version had this new
integration of being able to fold it to
make it more compact
so it looks like they're still going to
be doing that in this version but with
this nice little magnetic mount
they're real into creating magnetic
moments
here it is so it comes with a little
tripod
yes usbc little mount for your phone
and you can see the little magnetic
backing here the future
of possible
so this is a little riser pad for small
phones iphone 7
8 se2 and samsung s8 okay
and here we have the gimbal
right here so this looks to be about the
same size as the previous version so i
think the real difference between this
is the magnetic mount so it unfolds just
like so
yes i love that i just love being able
to fold this
and it's it's a good weight you can also
put this little tripod on the bottom
which is nice because you can not only
use this to
get really cool pano shots but you can
also use this
as an added little handle when you're
maneuvering this
what does this say this looks like it
says something important look at that
look at that important
text let's see what's in this little
package this looks like
something that there might be some food
in but i know there's not food i'm just
wishful thinking oh oh
look at this it's got like a nice little
carrying bag
so here's a little wrist strap that you
can put on the gimbal
so you can easily carry it around i love
these
huge fan this is something new this is
an alignment guide
so you line up your phone to be able to
attach
this little mount directly to the back
of your phone it's got like a little
sticky back to it
oh my gosh this is cool you just
you just line it up i feel like there's
probably something else in here
little things to clean oh my gosh are
these instructions
what kind of novel is this so the actual
directions
are one two barely three pages
translated into every possible language
that's pretty impressive
this is the little clamp that they have
so with this
you are able to just clamp this directly
onto your phone and then
this just magnetically
okay let's do it again tyler wants to
see it again are you ready
oh it's so scary it just snaps it right
into place
i love this because there's so many
times when we're out shooting i'm like
okay well i need my phone now
this is great i'm super hyped
and then with this little dude
you won't even need this mount you will
just
attach your phone directly to this it's
pretty strong
so one of the reasons that i probably
would mostly want to use this is if this
also didn't come off of here but this is
also magnetic which makes it really
easy to just put this on
and then i can just take my phone off
and on as well like this doesn't even
bother me at all
like this might be a permanent look for
me it's like a pop socket but not
hello you guys know that's fake because
i don't talk on the phone
so before i turn this on and get it all
paired up i want to show you some of the
previous versions just to show you kind
of where we were
and where we are now so this is the osmo
mobile 3. this is the previous version
it's a darker color but it's basically
the same
sort of size same form factor so if
you've used this previous version you'll
be very familiar with this one now
what's different though about this
is this is the foam clamp this doesn't
come off and that's one of the things
that i like about this is you can just
take this right off do whatever you need
to do
and magnetically put it back on so with
this every time you take your phone off
and on you'd have to make sure it was
perfectly aligned
where you had it previously so this just
makes it so much easier
this i don't even remember which one
this is this might have been
does it say anywhere does it say what
you are are you one of the first
ones you were an early friend you had to
actually
manually go in and move each one of
these pieces
see see this see this kids don't know
how good you have it nowadays you just
put your phone on the
gimbal and you go and make your movies
this is what we had to do back in our
day i had to manually
adjust my mobile gimbal how
did we survive back then where's number
two
i'm missing number two do you guys
remember
hold on a second i've got something i
found it
this piece of history back in my day
this is what we used to use do you
remember this
so this had the built-in camera this is
one of the original osmos you would
actually link your phone
up to it so that you could see what this
camera was seeing
this looks like some sort of like
futuristic little
what's that oh my god what was that
movie do you remember the movie where
there was a kid and he got in a
spaceship
and then something like this talked to
him fly to the navigator
yes yes no one knows what you're talking
about
you don't think so yeah but you knew
because i'm over 30. yeah i'm not over
30 what are you talking about
no i said i'm over you
[Music]
anyway things just keep getting better
and so far
i think this is my favorite one yet okay
we're ready to link you up now are you
ready are you ready
i guess we're gonna install the firmware
and then we'll test it out
oh it's almost done already what are the
really old movies do you like
did you remember mac and me it was also
like a little alien movie
yeah somehow one of the aliens was
hiding in our house
well i used alien hut in my backyard
johnny five
artificial intelligence has gotten too
smart
and then there was another one the
toasters and the aliens
battery's not included oh yeah i love
the osmo line so obviously the one with
the built-in camera
now they have the osmo pocket which is
we've covered before here on this
channel but that thing is so small just
to think that we
came from that massive thing now we're
here
it's pretty crazy it's auto calibrating
auto calibration
fixed itself so this is the little
trigger button so if we do three taps
that's how we switch the camera if you
are ever out shooting and you need to
kind of reset the camera angle you just
do two
and that resets it oh yeah we're gonna
be getting we're gonna be getting
the freaking shots man so here's our new
set and here's all of the settings so
you can kind of go in and this gives you
full control of your camera you can
change the resolution you can change
your speed at
the rate that you're recording you can
take photos so you have all of these
different manual settings that you're
able to adjust they also have these
really cool story modes
which are so fun these are not new
these are in the dji memo app so if you
have one of the osmos previously you've
probably seen those before and you've
probably seen me make them as well so we
have all of the same options that you
would have
you've got your story your panel which
is cool because you can do a three by
three
oh a cloney pano what is that oh my god
i'm gonna clone myself okay we're gonna
do it we're gonna do it we're gonna
freaking do it
okay i'm gonna clone myself right now
for optimal stitching the subject should
stay within the reference lines
all right wait wait i'm not there yet
[Music]
we've tried to manually do these before
and it doesn't really work that well
oh my gosh that's really fun that's
really cool expect me to be abusing
that feature so you can do a 240. maybe
i'll do it this way
okay there's tyler gesture control oh my
gosh there's gesture control as well
okay we're gonna just see what happens
oh it's happening it's happening it's
happening this is fast
[Music]
look at that no way let's see what else
we can do so this is gonna be a three by
[Music]
[Applause]
three
so because it's like a wide angle sort
of my face looks
i look really silly i feel like this is
probably better for like landscapes or
something
let's see what else we have i love the
gestures okay gesture control here's the
gestures so return gesture control on
so i have to say within two meters of
your phone so that's able to identify
your gesture
uh-oh we're doing another piano
so i'm going to turn off piano and take
a normal picture
okay so this is cool there's so much
more stuff i want to test out on here
but i feel like we should probably go
outside
maybe we mask up and go get a coffee
[Music]
okay tyler active track me draw around
me
is it working
[Music]
it's still following me it's your
competition right here tyler
look at that
[Music]
i mean can you could you do that that's
cool
that's cool now we'll do a double tap
brings it back to center look at that
[Music]
zoom
so while we're in the coffee shop we
tested out the story mode and i mean
obviously we weren't doing anything that
interesting what i love about story mode
is people can create a really fun
automated video like you don't have to
do anything like the camera will move
the shots for you and it will basically
edit together something
that you can post directly to social
well that's something i said
so far i've really been enjoying this i
think one of the things that i would
recommend
is be careful because this is magnetic
one of the things that i can potentially
see happening and i'm just giving you
guys this as a warning this can
potentially fall off so if you are
running or doing something crazy just be
careful because this
will come off of here because it is a
magnet it is really strong so i don't
imagine most people will have any issues
at all but just something to keep in
mind if you are using this
man i want to go somewhere cool and make
a cool video no
okay i'm bored in the house and i'm in
the house board who's bored in the house
me
yeah look at this look at me run look at
me run
look at me run look at me run look at me
run look at me run this is content
i don't know how many square feet this
is but what would you say how many i
don't know
how many square feet of entertainment do
you think that we're having right now
oh yeah wide angle wide angle looks like
it makes it look like we're having a lot
more square footage of fun oh yeah i'm
out of shape
you can also do hyper lapses and time
lapses on here and what i love is in the
software you're able to set in and out
points so you can actually have a moving
time lapse
so we will set the path with the
joystick
over here that's where we're going to
start and then we add our second one
and that will end over here here we go
fingers crossed
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope you guys enjoyed this video this is
the first look at the new osmo mobile 4.
i'd love to hear from you guys what do
you think do you use a gimbal for your
phone this really can elevate the shots
that you're able to get with your phone
and i cannot wait to try this out with
the next version of the iphone whatever
that is
whenever it will be i will be right here
waiting right here waiting
i don't know how the song goes i'm just
gonna delete i'm deleting myself
you